[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale la dernière
de cette saison sur tb 78 nous sommes le
lundi 8 juillet voici les titres de ce
journal la scène polluer après
l'incendié de l'usiné de traitement des
eaux usées près de saint germain en laye
ce week-end plus de trois tonnes de
poissons morts ont été repêchés du
fleuve la préfecture des yvelines tenait
une réunion en fin d'après-midi les
dernières informations dans ce journal
l'hommage à simone veil rendu par les
étudiants de l'ue vs qu ils ont rejoué
le débat parlementaire sur libé jélois
pro gül promulguée en 1975 la
reconstitution se dérouler en fin de
semaine dernière à l'assemblée nationale
et puis la chronique sport pour cette
dernière de la saison nous dressons le
bilan dans les yvelines analyse des tops
et flops c'est à la fin de cette édition
et dans ce journal nous parlerons aussi
des conseillers du commerce extérieur
qui viennent de donner leur prix de
l'international 2 yvelinois parmi les
lauréats et l'actualité également des
deux gourmands des producteurs de
biscuits c'est a créé pierre hermé
d'abord la sécheresse qui est présente
dans les yvelines depuis une quinzaine
de jours le seuil de vigilance a été
atteint en conséquence la préfecture des
yvelines invite 32 communes du sud du
département autour de rambouillet à
limiter leur consommation en eau est de
8 heures à 20 heures les habitants sont
priés de ne pas laver leurs voitures et
de ne pas arroser leur jardin privé est
les municipalités à ne pas arroser les
espaces verts publics la liste des
communes concernées sur le lit sur le
site de la préfecture des yvelines
les suites de l'incendié de l'usiné de
traitement des eaux usées près 2 saint
germain en laye un site avec la cie
seveso depuis les faits qui se sont
produits jeudi une pollution de la senne
est en cours avec des conséquences
environnementales bon format non varaldo
vous étiez sur place aujourd'hui et vous
nous donner les dernières informations
qu'elles sont elles sur le sujet le
bilan de l'incendié de la station
d'épuration d'achères le 3 juillet
dernier s'avère beaucoup plus lourd que
prévu
odeurs nausée
bond qui se dégage de la scène poissons
morts asphyxiés
tel est le constat que j'ai pu faire en
me rendant sur place si sa suite à cet
incendie une réunion d'information s'est
tenue cet après-midi à la
sous-préfecture de saint-germain-en-laye
avec la présence notamment de jean
jacques brot préfet des yvelines
les causes de l'incendié à l'usiné seine
aval du siaap sont toujours inconnues
130 pompiers étaient mobilisés
une nouvelle catastrophe écologique dans
un département déjà marquée par une
marée noire
le 24 février 2019 rappelez-vous suite à
la fuite d'un oléoduc appartenant à la
société total mais on en avait parlé
dans cette édition là du coup sûr cette
station d'épuration d'achères quelle est
la situation sur place le directeur du
site qui traite 60% des eaux usées
d'ile-de-france avait affirmé dans un
premier temps que quelques dizaines de
poissons étaient morts asphyxiés par des
zoos privés d'oxygène
au total c'est trois tonnes de poissons
morts qui ont été recueillis par un
bateau ce week-end entre achève et le
barrage d'andrésy le ramassage se
poursuit comme l'expliquent la
directrice adjointe de la cciab ça peut
prendre plusieurs jours pour vraiment
aller dans les moindres recoins des
poissons qui seraient coincés notamment
entre les péniches et les quais et
sachez qu'une quantité équivalente à 3
tonnes a été ramassées aujourd'hui dans
un bras mort du fleuve proche du point
de roger eddé aux retraités perd près de
l'île des rebelles merci m un nom pour
ces précisions et vous évoquez cette
réunion a donné par le préfet des
yvelines pour répondre aux questions des
élus et associations lors de celle-ci
les maires ont déploré le manque
d'information suite à cet épisode de
pollution inquiétudes et même ras-le-bol
du côté des habitants écouter à la scène
était propre depuis deux ans qu'ils ont
perdu en qualité baignade là tous les
sports nautiques sont interdits on peut
même pas se laver les mains
ça m'énerve de voir ça j'en ai marre
ras-le-bol je paye pour qu'on nous
polluent notre environnement c'est
simplement incroyable et de son côté la
fédération de génération écologie des
yvelines dénonce dans un communiqué la
lenteur des opérations de dépollution de
la scène l association paris à
hymne au zoo police appelle l le
ministère de la transition écologique et
solidaire à prendre des mesures des
dispositions pour protéger les habitats
des animaux et empêcher à nouveau ce
type de catastrophes et dans l'actualité
également ce drame à saint rémy les
chevreuse le cadavre d'une femme de 31
ans a été découvert à son domicile les
gendarmes se sont rendus sur place après
la déposition de son conjoint il s'est
rendu samedi en fin d'après-midi pour
avouer le meurtre de sa compagne la
victime est mort par strangulation une
dispute serait à l'origine de ce crime
l'homme a été placé en garde à vue
depuis le début de l'année près de 174
femme sont morts sous les coups de leur
compagnon ou ex conjoints pour enrayer
ce fléau la secrétaire d'état marlène
schiappa a annoncé la tenue d'un
grenelle des violences conjugales il
sera lancé en septembre par le
gouvernement il ya un an simone veil
faisait son entrée au panthéon jeudi
dernier les étudiants de l'ue vs qu lui
ont rendu hommage à travers une
reconstitution est du débat
parlementaire sur l'image et la loi a
été promulguée en 1975 csn ont été joués
dans le cadre de l'assemblée nationale
le reportage d' or ils iront z mika elle
me donne il ya 44 ans la loi veil
encadrant la dépénalisation de
l'avortement en france était adoptée à
l'assemblée nationale une scène rejouer
ce 3 juillet 2019 par 40 étudiantes et
étudiants de l'ue vs qu en revivant ses
segments importants pensent les
appropriant yayi ils ont une meilleure
appréhension des problèmes soulevés
meilleure compréhension des problèmes
soulevés et sûrement une mémoire plus
longue
tout un symbole pour lui vécu qui
donnait en 2012 le nom de simone veil à
son nouvelle ufr santé
cette reconstitution a permis aux
étudiants de revivre les débats houleux
de cette loi emblématique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'on a réussi à reconstituer
l'ambiance électrique de l'assemblée
nationale quelque chose que ce n'était
pas évident sous ces petites phrases ces
réactions ces insultes on a été assez en
adéquation avec le contexte actuel avec
l'alabama où finalement libéré n'est
plus autorisée et oui une prise de
conscience de se dire que on a une
chance incroyable qui finalement un jour
que je ne plus être autorisés étaient
présents dans l'assemblée le secrétaire
d'état pour la jeunesse gabriel attal ou
encore l'ancien ministre de la santé
marisol touraine
ils ne se sont pas contentés de jouer le
débat ils se le sont appropriés ont fait
en sorte de forte des questions
auxquelles on n'était pas forcément
préparé et attentif
il ya eu plusieurs moments de vrais
échanges j'ai trouvé entre les étudiants
eux mêmes et avec les participants au
débat
cette innovation pédagogique sera
reconduite par l'ue vs qu l'année
prochaine avec la reconstitution du
procès des médecins nazis de nour en
berne
en bref serge clément n'est plus le
directeur académique des yvelines il a
quitté son poste vendredi après avoir
démissionné un départ suite au
déclenchement d'une enquête
administrative demandée par la rectrice
de l'académie de versailles
une source proche du dossier citée par
le parisien évoque un comportement
déplacé de serge clément auprès de trois
collaboratrices il s'agirait d'une
affaire de harcèlement
un signalement aurait été défait au
parquet de versailles par l'académie l'
enquête confiée à la gendarmerie à serge
clément occupait ces fonctions depuis
décembre 2014 et c'est marie claire
duprat directrice adjointe est des
services départementaux de l'éducation
nationale qui assure actuellement
l'intérim politique il souhaite
reconstruire la droite
après les échecs successifs aux
élections aux différentes élections
gérard larcher réfléchir et à la
création de son propre label en vue des
municipales 2020 l illinois et président
du sénat proposerait à la france des
territoires le label serait apposée sur
les affiches de campagne il ne
remplacerait pas pour autant
l'investiture des candidats qui
pourraient se présenter sous l étiquette
les républicains ou divers droite
les deux étudiants yvelinois récompenser
le 28 juin dernier ils ont reçu le grand
prix de l'international c'était au
collège des bernardins à paris il s'agit
de kévin chapuzet et de vous guénaëlle
latinier bonsoir ça faisait donc
lauréate de ce prix dans la catégorie
bac + 2 à bac + 3 vous êtes du lycée
notre-dame de grand champ à versailles
dans lequel vous avez suivi un bts avec
nous également
joselyne pardon joselyne studio lorenzi
hier soir alors vous êtes vous donc vice
président de la commission nationale
formation pour les cce sont les
commerces les conseillers du commerce
extérieur qui sont à l'origine de ce
prix déjà qui sont ils c'est alors nous
sommes 4300 dont 12 en france brest dans
le monde
nous sommes une institution qui a 120
ans nous sommes bénévoles nommés par le
premier ministre un décret trois ans
renouvelable d'accord si on remplit bien
nos missions quelles sont nos missions
sont volution la première le conseil aux
pouvoirs publics
quand on est à l'étranger évidemment pas
si le conseil qui revient du terrain
puisque nous sommes des hommes et des
femmes de terrain et professionnels
patron ou patron des affaires
internationales enfin la paix surtout
d'autres missions l'attractivité de
notre territoire
donc même quand on est à l'étranger ou
quand on est ici c'est à dire avoir créé
l'envi que la france soit un pays
intéressant pour les investisseurs
étrangers
une autre mission qui le mentorat pour
les pme qui doivent se développer à
l'international
un soutien aux veilleux ou ontarien
internationale aux entreprises et
surtout la formation la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes là pour récompenser
une étudiante donc la formation nous ne
sommes pas des professeurs mais nous
sommes là pour donner des envies le
plaisir est mobilisé pour développer le
commerce international chez nous vers le
formation important et vous avez
organisé donc la septième édition de ce
concours de l' international qui
récompense justement elle est jeune
talent français pour leur travail
académique à l'international vous guanel
vous avez été récompensé à suite à une
mission de prospection à hong kong pour
la distribution de produits venant
d'afrique déjà votre réaction suite à ce
prix de recevoir ce prix l'international
j'étais très honoré et très ému à la
fois ça permet de 20
reese est un travail de deux ans pour la
préparation au concours est également
les deux mois sur hong kong
et ça permet de prouver aux gens qui ont
eu confiance en moi de qu'ils ont bien
fait de mettre leur confiance en moi
j'espère continuer à leur prouver que je
mérite ce prix survient juste sur votre
parcours le goût pour l'international ça
vous a accompagnés oui j'ai commencé dès
le lycée
je suis partie un en australie en
famille d'accueil ensuite en espagne en
famille d'accueil également et j'ai
décidé d'abandonner la voie scientifique
pour laquelle je m'étais formé au départ
et de me tourner vers le bts commerce
international pour continuer vers
l'international on va revenir juste dans
un instant sur votre expérience du coup
on le disait en bleu formation très
important ce 7ème édition de ce prix
quel est le principe et comment est-il
organisé sur le principe
comme vous l'avez vu nous sommes des
professionnels de terrain donc on part
du terrain donc ce sont nos différents
comités qui sont sur toute la france qui
nous présentent leur premier prix en bts
ou bac + 3 ou bac + 4/5 et ensuite nous
sélectionnons les meilleurs alors
parfois cément travaux académiques mais
mission et puis l'épreuve terrible c'est
15 minutes d'entretien avec jean marc
vittori quel président notre jury du
vitoria liste les échos et où là on va
savoir si l'étudiant ou l'étudiante ont
vraiment le virus l'envi le dynanisme
d'aller plus loin les objectifs du coup
quels sont ils
l'objectif c'est de promouvoir nos
jeunes qui ont des talents à
l'international pour pouvoir aller plus
loin parce qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin en
france de développer notre commerce
international et d'avoir des jeunes
recrues qui vont prendre le relais donc
notre objectif c'est de récompenser et
de montrer ce que ça faire nos jeunes
pour les départager vous le disait il ya
eu un petit entretien oui alors au
départ par des mémoires
là il ya une première sélection en
quinze mois après une première édition
il en reste neuf
après on a cet entretien de 15 minutes
chacun au téléphone comme ça on est très
très terrible et puis ensuite bien on
récompense les meilleurs cette année ça
a été difficile parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup
très bon travaux et de très bons
étudiants tant qu'hôte ça vous donne
encore plus de crédit gouel alors vous
avez effectué vous un instant je le
disais de demain on compte c'était en
2017 c'est ça vous avez fait de la
prospection pour la start-up roumaine
qui produit et commercialise des noix de
cajou notamment des noix de cajou
ivoirienne pourquoi ce secteur pourquoi
ils vous intéresser c'est en fait je
voulais partir hong kong de base et du
coup je me suis mis en contact avec nos
conseillers des commerce extérieur
spécialisé sur la chine
et là il m'a présenté plein de projets
dont le projet de la start-up coup men
qui était de produire des noix de cajou
et d'autres produits comme du miel du
lait etc en afrique avec un savoir faire
français et l'exporter en asie et je
suis tombée amoureuse de ce projet j'ai
décidé d'embarquer avec eux et de les
aider à développer le côté plus
prospection et clientèle en partant
aaron pour eux durant des mois mais
qu'est ce que vous allez vous avez fait
concrètement par mois à hong kong
alors il ya eu deux phases une phase de
prospection facile une phase de
prospection active avec étude de marché
étude pays et ensuite une phase de
prospection active où j'ai rencontré des
distributeurs et des importateurs où
j'ai fait une étude linéaire en rendant
dans les diverses grandes surfaces pour
avoir une approche plus globale du
marché et avoir des contacts pour la
start-up telle vie dont vous vous direz
alors un peu plus de deux ans de la fin
de ce stage meilleur au final le projet
de votre cadeau et un terrain peu trop
ambitieux pour une start up
est-ce qu'il va falloir faire c'est se
tourner vers un projet qui va regrouper
plein de start-up franco africaines pour
des projets des produits plus exotiques
comme du miel mono floral du lait de
fruits de jouve y est c est de percer
ensuite le marché asiatique
pas seulement avec le produit anacarde
et la suite pour vous des événements
avec cette expérience est aussi ce prix
que vous avez reçu actuellement chez à
grenoble école de management pour parce
que c'est une école spécialisée dans la
géopolitique et le but ce serait avoir
un terme de faire des veilleux avec les
pensées du commerce extérieur et
pourquoi pas travailler pour
l'entreprise dagen fly qui est mon
parrain des de ce prix et qui est
spécialisé
les ressources humaines à hong kong et
en chine une huitième édition les
prochains à bercy
oui et on va souhaiter longue vie à ce
prix et au parent qui apporte aussi non
seulement leurs réseaux mais qui
financent plus donc c'est quelque chose
de très important
merci à vous et joselyne spyder lawrence
pour lé conseiller du commerce extérieur
bravo à vous gwenaëlle à l'atelier
lauréate du grand prix de
l'international merci d'être passé en
plateau une idée de sortie à présent ce
début des vacances d'été c'est jusqu'au
19 juillet la 8e édition adua village
sportif et culturel à lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines une
vingtaine d'activités est proposé à tous
les visiteurs des sportifs
professionnels sont même sur place pour
conseiller les jeunes découvertes du
programme avec patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas d'ombré look et sur
gazon la nouveauté du village sportif et
culturel 2019 à lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines des sports des
activités culturelles proposées aux
jeunes de 11 à 17 ans certains ateliers
sont animés par des sportifs de haut
niveau c'est le cas de jérémy aicardi
anciens joueurs de l'équipe de france de
rugby à 7
si aujourd'hui j'ai envie de transmettre
c'est parce que tout ce que j'ai appris
pendant ma carrière en tout cas
professionnels mais surtout avancer les
valeurs du rugby le portage les copains
plaisir que le coach tangle ou pas te
félicite quand tu fais des belles
actions avec des créneaux d'une heure
par ateliers les jeunes peuvent
découvrir des sports inhabituel escalade
ventriglisse et sandball ou encore une
activité d'équitation d'une durée d'une
heure trente du sport mais pas seulement
également on pourra retrouver de
l'initiation aux gestes qui sauvent bas
pour apprendre justement les gestes de
premiers secours et sur la partie
culturelle on va retrouver notamment un
atelier radio avec l fm radio une
exposition du cnoss donc sur une
exposition autour des jeux olympiques
illégalement est intégré l'exposition
trajectoire j'ai une exposition sur la
mobilité le village sportif et culturel
c'est du 8 au 19 juillet inscription
obligatoire en 2018 près de 800 jeunes
ont participé à cet événement et avant
mai prochain vite il m'a rejoint
également en plateau c'est mikel et demi
d'euros vincent rigaud rue pour la
chronique sports du lundi c'est la
dernière de cette saison et oui
aujourd'hui
alors pour cette dernière vous allez
nous proposer des tops et des flops de
la saison sportive dans le département
et oui et on commence par les flops et
et oui il y a eu quelques déceptions
dans les yvelines j'insiste bien sur
déception dans ses flops on retrouve des
équipes
oudéa sportif qui on aurait aimé voir au
plus haut niveau
en football américain pressenti pour
aller en d1 les templiers d'elancourt
n'augmenteront pas cette année favori la
rencontre ils se sont inclinés en
play-off de 2e division les élans
pourtant été battu par les gladiateurs
de la queue en brie en demi-finale de
conférence 15 à 10 et s'incline à ce
niveau pour la deuxième année
consécutive une vraie déception pour le
club qui végète rats en deuxième
division pour la quatrième année
consécutive continue sur les flops avec
de la boxe alors notre deuxième flop
concerne donc la boxe et plus
particulièrement à marvin petit l'élan
courtois perdu pour la deuxième fois de
sa carrière le boxer surnommé le gitan
s'est incliné aux points face aux belges
francesco patera en février dernier en
belgique
il ne deviendra donc pas champion ebu
européen des poids légers cette année
depuis marvin petit n'est pas remonté
sur un ring alors 3e flop ce qui aura
trois flops trois tops cette séquence
flop avec du handball l'icann on va pour
la direction de plaisir plaisir qui n'a
pas à réussi à réaliser
une saison en nationale 3 le désir oies
qui avait accédé à cette division en
2017 ont connu une année compliquée les
joueurs de victor garrigues et n'a
remporté que six victoires en vente 22
matches disputés des résultats qui
n'aurait pas été suffisant sur le papier
pour se maintenir le club termine 10ème
sur 12 mais réussit tout de même à se
maintenir in extremis dans la division
suite un repêchage
une mesure qui va permettre à plaisir de
conserver ses meilleurs éléments et
surtout ces jeunes hors pack des flops
il y aussi des touches positive cette
saison forcément des tops
on commence par du rugby le club des
versets et connu une saison
extraordinaire des joueurs de la cité
royale ont été invaincus cette saison
ils ont emporté largement tous les
matches de phase de poules ils ont
emporté le titre de champion ile de
france en s'imposant contre vincennes en
finale les performances qui vont leur
permettre de monter en fédérale 3
l'année prochaine
seul bémol les verse ayant perdu contre
vesoul aux tirs au but en championnat de
france deuxième top c'est un événement
international auquel vous avez participé
legueulle donc journaliste qui a
exactement le golfe et l'organisation de
la ryder cup 2018 la compétition était
organisée au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines en septembre dernier
l'événement a réuni sur les greens les
plus grandes stars internationales de la
discipline comme tiger woods ou rory
mcilroy dans les tribunes 270 mille
personnes sont venues assister à la
compétition
et puis d'un milliard de personnes ont
regardé à la télé on regarde à la
télévision la compétition était
tellement réussie que des rumeurs sur
une nouvelle candidature du golf
national de circulent mais on termine
par quoi nickel mon dernier top concerne
l'équipe de baseball des cougars de
montigny le bretonneux lésigny montrent
un an terminé finaliste de première
division en septembre dernier
pour cette nouvelle saison ils ont
réussi à terminer troisième d'une coupe
d'europe pour la première fois de leur
histoire
même s'il n'arriveront pas être
finaliste cette saison en championnat
l'année est déjà réussie pour les
cougars
merci michael on vous retrouve dans le
sud sports dans un instant où vous ferez
un bilan de la saison c'est sa sportive
dans le département exactement je
m'échauffais injustement mais restait en
tout cas quelques minutes avec vous je
sais que vous êtes un gourmand il ya en
tout cas deux gourmands avec noé
également sur ce plateau on va parler de
cette marque de biscuits de produits qui
nous viennent des yvelines ses deux co
fondateurs sont avec moi c'est louis
bataille à gauche et guillaume qui a
fait un bon soir alors vous produisez
des biscuits
niel également à crêpière le tout en
respect avec l'environnement il expliqué
nous cette démarche vertueuse pourquoi
elle vous tient à coeur est et comment
vous la mettez en place cette démarche
vertueuse
alors après un départ c'est d'abord
notre notre hameau pour le local pour
notre région et on s'est retrouvé là
dessus avec lui on est frères de coeur
mais aussi frère de valeur et on avait
envie d'avoir de développer un projet
qui ait du sens pour nous et quoi de
mieux qu on pouvait parler de sa région
que de le faire par de bons produits
autour d'un bon repas nous d'abord c'est
le biscuit pourquoi parce qu'on les
phénomènes dans notre ferme à klépierre
ensuite on utilise d'abord des
ingrédients locaux de notre région
des ingrédients qui ont été cultivés en
agriculture biologique ou de manière
raisonnée au pire donc ça reste très bon
et puis on met en avant dans nos
producteurs les gens avec qui on
travaille
la région toujours c'est c'est ça le
point départ d'abord on le sent louis
dans les propos de dieu c'était une
évidence de vous lancer dans cette
aventure
exactement c'est bas presque la passion
on est gourmand avant tout et on avait
vraiment à coeur de mettre en avant le
local mettre en avant les producteurs
qui sont proches de chez nous pour
redonner un peu de la confiance dans
tout ce qu'on consomme qu'on a commencé
avec des biscuits sucrés maintenant des
biscuits salés on est aussi apiculteur
donc on a nos ruches paraît dans la
région et l'idée c'est de n'avoir des
produits toujours plus gourmands est
toujours au plus proche de nos
consommateurs donc vraiment c'est le
local en avant à travers à travers tout
le dilemme de produits et en quel goût
par exemple vous proposer pour les
biscuits vous êtes revenu actuel des
biscuits quel goût vous proposer six
proposés dans l'égout emblématique ce
qu'ils font l'unanimité on a le bisc
coquelicot keane spécialité de nemours
en seine-et-marne le biscuit au chocolat
avec la chocolaterie d'hardricourt pas
très loin non plus notre biscuits au
miel évidemment c'est le notre miel du
gâtinais gonds qu'on m'aide en cédant
ses biscuits pour notre cette voie là on
a aussi des temps des épices et toute
une gamme qu'on a pas rapporté la de cac
cookies granola il ya un réseau internet
qui s'affiche donc on retrouve bien sûr
la gamme de produits et ça je dirais que
c'est notre c'est la factualité le
développement des nouvelles recettes
alors qu'ils sont d'abord disponible
dans notre ferme donc là on invite à
tous les locaux à nous retrouver
on a une boutique sur place et la
deuxième actualité c'est un événement
qu'on organise en septembre prochain le
14 et 15 septembre exactement ce qu'on
appelle fêtes de la plaine
parce qu'on est situé au coeur de la
plaine de versailles et là c'est une
journée portes ouvertes
donc on peut visiter la biscuiterie la
miellerie ont fait de la restauration
sur place
ce seront des crêpes un poulet rôti
frites voilà tout ça local fermiers et
c'est un super moment parce qu'on a
aussi concerts toute la journée le soir
le dimanche aussi
voilà c'est un moment qu'on veut festif
on veut vraiment convié les gens notre
entourage le local à nous retrouver gêne
ou à la ferme et quads le connaît mieux
que de faire par une fête
voilà donc un événement festif autour
des produits locaux alors sur
l'actualité si on parle aussi de la
production de vos produits je crois
qu'ils sont déjà à plus de 50 % bio et
l'idée c'est d'aller vers plus de bio
encore c'est ça oui avant tout c'est le
local donc vraiment travaillé sur la
proximité on va chercher les meilleurs
ingrédients qu'on a au plus proche de
chez nous autour de chez nous on
n'arrive pas tout avoir en bio encore
aujourd'hui
pour prendre l'exemple du sucre par
exemple si on veut un sucre bio en
l'état aujourd'hui il faut aller les
chercher de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
d'accord l'impact global selon nous et
est moins bon si on prend un sucre bio
qui vient de plus loin
mais les choses changent les choses
évoluent et on tend justement vers le
bio et local et c'est vraiment le la
volonté de notre démarche et l'autre
actualité aussi en tout cas c'est dans
vos projets futurs c'est celui de
reprendre la ferme de vos parents c'est
ça effectivement donc cette ferme c'est
pas n'importe quelle ferme
moi j ai grandi c'est un corps cultivée
par par mes parents aujourd'hui donc le
projet c'est de reprendre cette ferme
cultiver nous même de convertir en
agriculture biologique
les cultures en place et progressivement
parce que notre volonté c'est de nous
impliquer et puis de faire de plus en
plus nous mêmes toujours au plus près de
la terre c'est d'utiliser un jour les le
blé bio qui poussera sur cette firme
qu'on aura cultivé d'écraser en faire de
la farine et puis utilisant de
l'utiliser dans nos biscuits c'est à
dire au final faire vos habitudes
vraiment de a à z
en tout cas en maximum pour des brutes
jusqu'aux produits transformés
exactement l'idée derrière c'est comment
retrouver confiance dans nos produits
c'est ça aussi le local c'est la
confiance et transparence et la
confiance c'est ce qui peut se perdre un
petit peu aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on a ce marché donc c'est ça
l'idée les deux gourmands
c'est dans cet objectif là avec aussi
l'objectif d'ouvrir une chocolaterie sur
place ça c'est en tout cas c'est en
réflexion et peut-être il y en a plein
de projets pleins d'idées
effectivement pour compléter ce que des
et guillaume l'idée d'origine du produit
du projet c'est de de reconnecter le
consommateur a vraiment l'agriculture en
amont donc quoi de mieux que le faire si
on cultive notre propre produit et donc
de faire vivre cette ferme
l'activité de la faire venir des gens
sur place fabriquée toujours plus de
produits sur cette ferme effectivement
dans l'est dans les projets qui sont en
train de mûrir de notre côté un projet
de chocolaterie qui pourrait voir le
jour dans la ferme mais on suit votre
actualité bien sûr sur le site internet
qui s'affiché retenez cette date 14 et
15 septembre fête est de la plaine c'est
à la ferme donc à crêpière venez fêter
les produits locaux avec nos deux
gourmands merci à venir elle est
repassée en plateau voilà c'est la fin
du set 8 journal le replay est bien sûr
à consulter sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile belle soirée
sûreté des 78
[Musique]